I like to only hold hands
what no I just don't spoil oh if you're
going to hold hands it's good it's
totally fine let's ask a question guys
that I'm sure isn't not anybody's mind
um what's going on here I didn't watch
paradise and I really didn't watch
Rachel season because I'm all over the
world all the time I didn't know much
about Dean I saw his cute little face in
those big blue eyes and kind of it went
from there I don't know anything about
her
okay I just know that she has big
beautiful meatball eyes and that's very
different than how a lot of people know
Dean what do you like about Leslie as a
person where do I start
oh my god I think we'll get very
familiar with Leslie story through
winter games which I know she kind of
felt like she talked a lot a lot about
it but I think it speaks a lot sir she's
a very courageous person and she's
strong and I think that's first and
foremost what really attracted me to her
and of course she's beautiful and if you
want to talk about someone that's kind
to everyone it's her it's kind of
annoying when we go places and she
literally makes friends with it every
single person we meet and a lot of
endearing qualities like that so I'm
excited few guys to kind of see them
kind of weed it off right away so it was
nice to kind of be able to there were no
love triangles this season
okay she made well sure hear that so we
are gonna get a different Dean than we
saw on paradise for shorts
[Music]